am so struck that time and again and I
list the extraordinary women who've held
their ground on this one time and again
the the
Target of the most virulent trans
activists are women now there is so much
in this you can unpack but it happened
in Manchester where a group of women's
rights activists have a meeting and male
to female transsexuals are banging on
the Windows whilst the police are
standing around allowing it whilst these
women are being intimidated in the
building now what is this well several
things one is and let's be frank about
this one is deep disgust hatred and envy
of people born women
definitely going on